[Music]
you got this new gig at NBC the new show
how's it going you enjoying yourself so
far I'm not mad you know you you've been
forbidden to say the title of my show no
not at all okay hustle hustle and flow
no that's that's my movie that's your
movie honey you don't know the title of
the show kids kids it's going great it's
going great we had a low scandal onset I
didn't hear that yeah we called it
Nipplegate
Nipplegate yeah yeah apparently my
nipples are too large for my t-shirts
being serious speed serious so I was on
set one day and I wore my wardrobe guy
Tommy came over and he's like hey
Anthony did you put those pasties on
that I put in your room and I was like
no man I thought that was a joke because
we had a joke that my nipples are gonna
poke somebody's eye out if he keep
putting me any small t-shirts right and
he was like no no no you came down from
Network so their network they were they
where they decided that your nipples
were distracting on my nipples were
distracting I really want just to be the
fly on the wall when that meeting took
place is I hey guys think the shows
numbers were great last night the show
was coming along but Anthony's nipples
distracting to anyone but me right and
apparently was distracting to the entire
brass at NBC so what they did is they
decided that you need to wear pasties
I wear pasties every Tuesday when we
tape our show over your nipples over my
nip we have a still here this is a still
from the show this is pre that's the
culprit
those are pronounced yes sir we didn't
need it arrows no you know I know
yeah I mean I like thumbs yeah so this
is been a this has been alive been
totally checking out your nipples since
you brought it up yeah this is what I
wear this is what they have you wear
yeah I don't need these get started no
no I'm just cuz it's like adhesive
around the outside but then the inside
is like soft so your nipple can breathe
like I saw a picture of you today our
producer found it it's from quite a
while ago what year was this tell us
what's going on here that was the year
of the jheri curl the jheri curl that
was my high school senior photo min 1988
1988 19 1988 that was me and my Jericho
and the shiny suit before p-diddy
that's oh yeah the shiny shiny suit now
explain jheri-curl to me because I've
never liked what's what's involved I'm
fascinated with hair and hair products
I've never gone the jheri curl
Wow nobody's managin but you are
fascinated products because we love your
hair thank you very much yes America
does but I'm curious I'm curious well
it's it's it's a process it was invented
by a gentleman in San Diego where they
would put a solution on your hair like a
lie relaxer and they would curl it up
and leave it on for a couple of hours
for it to set right and then put you
under a hair dryer and then wash it out
and it changes the texture of your hair
now did you stick with that look for a
while or the minute you rise oh no boss
oh yeah I had that look for about that I
grew up in confidence so that was a
staple in Compton California right right
there that was your rites of passage
right growing that to have that look
hood to survive yes so I kept that for I
had Jericho from me about eight years
but I went to Howard University so I was
my senior high school senior yearbook
picture so I cut it because I was going
to the mecca of all black universities
Howard University and I couldn't show up
with a jheri curl right so I cut it off
and I kept it in a ziploc bag what for
three and a half
why would you do that it was it was a
science experiment
[Laughter]
throw another guy so three and a half
years later I came back home and I went
through my top drawer and I said oh my
bag of hair and it was it was here man
we all did that when we came back from
college where's my back hair but what
was crazy I put some solution back on it
and the hair curled right back up yeah
you can glue it right back on again and
then you're right back where you need to
be there you go fantastic